this is Britain in the early 1970s a
time of industrial unrest and trade
union standoffs
[Music]
when petrol shortages briefly ground us
to a halt an era when glam rock called
the charts there were only three
television channels efficient chips was
the takeaway of choice that's what I
hear anyway I wasn't around in 1973 when
Britain joined the Common Market
strengthening our bond with the
continent that relationship will endure
beyond our exit from the EU but now is a
good time to consider how Europe has
changed the way we live from the clothes
we wear to the food we and how we spend
our time and what better place to start
than with the national game this match
at Wembley celebrated our arrival in the
common market a team captained by Bobby
Charlton representing the home nations
world to Charton and perfect crusty
Empson ago they faced aside representing
the six existing common market countries
it was victory for Charlton's men and
five years later a European decree gay
football as the freedom to play anywhere
at Brentford FC the influx of European
players started later there Griffin Park
ground in West London is a symbol of
traditional English football
the trip to the pub is all part of the
game for Gerry and his mates the same
could have been said for the players
that was before European coaches arrived
in the top flight bringing some
continental discipline wasn't just the
town's football clubs the high street
was changing too
[Music]
by the mid-1990s some of the biggest
names in British football were from the
continent Eric Cantona with his mix of
French arrogance and extraordinary skill
John Franco Zola and Gianluca Vialli
bringing Italian flair and the ingenuity
of Germany Jurgen Klinsmann totally new
experience for me in England it wasn't
just the Europeans coming over here
the first away trips to Europe walked in
a window to a new world for travelling
fans answer Teasdale among them in
Salford or curvy or Leeds
then you've got the factory you've got
terraced houses and not much else but
suddenly you're in Switzerland and
there's people drinking very small beers
that are very cold and undressing in
leisure where with crocodiles on it and
trainers where they're strapped and
velcro straps and this is another world
the world of Mediterranean sand tennis
clubs and skiing and it's just
incredibly pleasant and what it did it
gave young men tend to look for
adventure and this in the late 70s
nearly 18 was the passport to adventure
where football fans went first all those
quickly followed the birth of local
snare lines meant the advent of the
European we can break
for some young people this was a cheap
ticket to foreign hedonism returning
with their eyes opened we imported the
ax beef and way of clubbing into the UK
started in London then Manchester which
was that you were being exposed to
strange things men kissing transvestites
people who saw eight fire for a living
in Tarzan thongs and that you could
experience all that Anna be thin Michael
and the beef a nightclub with no roof it
wasn't just an appetite for European
partying but their food too when you are
being exposed to foreign cuisine let's
say you know you get a taste for it you
know 1972 he wanted a salient food you
have to make do with spaghetti hoops on
toast well that's a start towards the
evening meal this used to be the epitome
of oak cuisine
[Music]
and at the oldest delicatessen in
Scotland Francesca continent her parents
used to be the tastemakers that changed
as European travel became cheaper and
easier for many years you know it's been
we've been trying to tempt people and
let them try things and let them teach
to enjoy things and explain how you cook
them but now the reverse is happening
and people are coming to us have you got
X Y and Zed because they've they've
either traveled and you know tried in
Calabria and now they want to see if
they can get in in Scotland we used to
sell Prosecco and in the 80s we
introduced it in Scotland and not a lot
of places sold it nobody knew what it
was you know we'd go through you a
couple of cases a year and now of course
Prosecco is is the drink of the nation
as Europe has become more familiar it's
exotic ism has dissolved some reflect
wistfully on the pre Europe years as a
time of simplicity always disagree
there's nothing innocent about living in
England in the post-industrial period
after the war
it's a tough period it was it was
violent more violent than today
certainly and having to eat not great
food and not missing out on great music
and nice experiences isn't something to
me of a golden age England was known as
the sick man of Europe for a reason that
doesn't mean it was all bad but I think
the more culture that we are exposed to
the better
whether you wanted to leave Europe or
not the influence the continent has had
on our everyday lives is inescapable and
probably irreversible from the food we
eat to the clothes we wear and how we
spend our time exit for me doesn't mean
rewinding four to seven years
this is Britain 2020